Christian Elder, Screenwriter: Here's a great test of writing something or
anything for any writer and it's a simple one.
Film Courage: I have a little bit of a writing
challenge we can try and I'm hoping you can
help me to make this small bit of information
better. I'm going to read it to you so my story
is about a young writer trying to break through
(whatever breakthrough means). We'll call him
Joe and he's a good guy from a small town his
parents were hippie artists, not a lot of money
but they supported his move to Los Angeles. While
writing during the day and very tired at night
from these humbling like grunt jobs, Joe meets
someone who decides to take him under his wing
and it's a producer who says “I like your work and
it needs some polish but I'm going to help you,”
and so the young writer Joe is just like “Wow
this is my dream come true.” I call my parents
and they say we're so proud of you we always
knew you'd succeed and then after about a year,
reality sets in for Joe. Joe starts to see that
he's being used and sometimes abused and this
producer not only steals Joe's ideas but he
has Joe do a lot of his personal dirty work,
like go spy on his tenants, go spy on his
wife and also pick up his dry cleaning and
then he has him writes scathing reviews on a
former nemesis and he takes those reviews and
he uses them his own because he used to be in a
literary world so he has Joe review some of this
other person's work and then writes these these
reviews and then he publishes them as his own.
How can we clean this up? This is about like a
story of a young writer who's really hungry to be
in the business but he starts to see wait a minute
I'm in a bad element right here. I'm in a bad way.
Christian: For those of you who have worked in
the agency world this is the story of an assistant
okay is that the log line that's the long line
no it is that's what it is it's the story of an
assistant and it's the tame version oh okay wow
all right okay so mine's for all auditors okay
great no it's true actually actually some you
know some insistence would be going oh no it's
much worse than that but yeah no so what's the
why what's the purpose of this the purpose is
fines goodness is taken advantage of okay and
and my reflection on this is how can I clean
it up to tell the story better because it's
not just the idea but it's how I'm telling it
well it's first of all you have to
shorten the shorten how you say it
you have to you have to turn it into a a
concise bit of wording it has to become
a log line or a premise it has to be something
that you can issue briefly that has a bit of a
snap to a bit of a hook something that
pulls you in so that is number one and
so not to say that it doesn't have it but you
have to you have to find it in there a story
is is sometimes like like a block of
marble and and and you're the sculptor
and you have to you have to find the form in
the marble what you have right now is marble
and you need to find the form Michelangelo used
to say I don't know if you've ever been to Italy
but it's one of the most beautiful
things you've ever seen is the David
but Michelangelo used to say that he would look at
the the block of marble and he could see inside of
it to form and and it's proven that he he did
because at the academia where the where the
the David sits it's flanked on both sides
by by his sculptures known as the slaves
and the slaves were unfinished because I think
it was towards the towards the end of his life so
Michelangelo basically chiseled straight
in to the marble towards the form
he didn't like other sculptors whittle all the
way around the marble Farm to get to the form he
went right to it so he'd be an arm sticking out
of the block there'd be a leg partially in the
block and the rest would be all just raw marble so
that's what you got there is a bunch of raw marble
and you have to get to the form that's inside
and the forum would be your the germ absolute
germ of your story the log line okay so maybe
the log line it's too long but it could be a
premise it could be it's a long line it would
just be one sentence correct yeah technically
it's one sentence sure or so it one or two
sentences okay so then Joe young writer finds
out that goodness isn't always rewarded in
entertainment that's a little broad it’s Joe
a young writer is enthralled by a
mentor in the Hollywood industry
and moves to Los Angeles to
find success and instead becomes
enslaved to a powerful man that's more along the
lines of of what you're looking for I tweak it a
little bit more make it a little a little better
around there but yeah that's what you'd be looking
for okay and and Joe who would he have as his
supporting character so we have this producer
who's like the nemesis in some ways and then
would he have a roommate how can we make Joe
his dialogue with someone to actually tell them
about what's happening who would Joe be bouncing
ideas off of in this story I don't know you you're
telling me the story so who do you think Joe would
be bouncing the ideas off of it sounds like you'd
think there would be a roommate or there could be
a coffee girl oh sorry no yeah there could be a
coffee girl and Joe could could be going through
a lot of things I mean the question is who is
Joe and who is Joe why is Joe you know what
what is what what what really motivates Joe that
all tells you a lot of things as well you know
that you don't you don't need to have
attendant cliches to to make any kind of story
in fact avoiding them informs who informs a
very often often a unique way of subverting them
avoiding them it allows you to go down at
idiosyncratic Road where you start to come up
with some really original stuff so you sometimes
you want to get around that it's like what if what
what why is it why is it a coffee girl what
if he's gay that's true coffee boys what if
it said yeah well it's a coffee coffee point you
know roommate roommate why is he what if he lives
what if he lives with the with the with the
producer what if he lives in the producers
garage he makes him live in the garage what if he
sleeps in his car what if he sleeps in his car.
Now something's visually now I'm starting to think
what if he sleeps in his car lots of lots of young
people come out to places and they're they're
poor and they and and they have to they have to
sleep in their car that's something I read about
that's something I hear about on NPR or the crummy
weekly hotel yeah exactly exactly there's there's
all these other things you roads you can go down
to to avoid those tropes and and it's good that
you do because you're going to get a more original
piece of work out of it okay so I see yes so the
cliche young writer with the the proud parents
back home that maybe that that's that's boring
okay so then what if we talked about what if
the dad had a gambling addiction and he gambled
away his college tuition and so he wasn't able to
get a creative writing degree so he comes here
to LA and it's not a coffee girl what if it's
someone who does drag at night at a club okay
and basically tells them the real deal and has
no we'll just tell him how it is and he he trusts
that person because they don't want anything from
him okay so then and he basically says the the
let's say the drag is Terry by night and then
Terence by day and then so make it interesting
like just not the typical that's beginning to
be something I want to see or read okay okay you
see what I'm saying right you're doing it you're
you're doing it right now you're going down those
off-roads and it's starting to make me curious to
the point where like oh that's something I haven't
seen before I'm interested in seeing or reading it
here's a here's a great test of of writing
something or anything for any writer and it's
a simple one it's like write what you want to see
write the thing that you've never seen before that
you're like oh I really like to see someone make
a movie about that what what an idea what what a
novel idea I'll write the thing that's never been
done that I've always wanted to see done so then I
have to ask what happens to Joe and how does he
ultimately reconcile with that job or leave it
and and then I have to plan out does he quit does
he get fired does something happen to the producer
does the producer get arrested because maybe
the producer had a shady business on the side
that no one knew about maybe he was involved
in Auto he was part of a ring of automobile
scams so he was in on it with doctors lawyers,
workers compensation all this stuff so he's in
on this and that's how he was really making his
money and that's how he's funding the movies
and then he gets arrested and there's
a padlock on the house and the garage
and Joe's stuff is inside he's got to get it
out so the sheriff has to come and let him in
and then he goes back home well yeah you could
do that okay you could do that as long as it's
organic as long as you feel that it's organic
and what you're telling me sounds fairly organic
but if it's not organic if anything happens
the does not seem organic to you as the writer
you should run from screaming in a run just
run screaming from anything that doesn't feel
organic and natural to the characters this is
something we haven't talked about is character is
that your character and what you've done is you
built up a character a character profile more
so than a long line or a premise and and through
that character profile you have you've you have
used that as a template to draw out what potential
actions would occur given that situation so now we
since we know who Joe's character is we we get
a sense of how that will play out character is
a very very funny thing it's very very funny the
reason why it's funny is because it's prescient
it's a cute little tool because it it strings
you along with like oh this is the like it's not
going to go where you think it is but in a way
it always will so it's a it's this little trick
it's like it's like it like gives you enough bread
crumbs to go okay it's going to go exactly where
you think it is but it it's going to look like
it doesn't and that's what you do with character
you set you set up the reader or the audience
based upon the person's Behavior this also
works in tandem with with telling your story
in the cut and loading up your exposition and
I'm between those cuts because if you're if you
show the behavior of your character for example
and you'll see this and stuff like Lonergan
does this did this in in Manchester by the Sea
it's like if you I go into a
bar and and I get into a brawl
every time I'm going to go into a bar in this
movie you don't even have to see me in the bar
you know there's going to be a brawl
happening so that that's the thing
that you can do with character that is that
is really really fun and is really really rich
that's basically that I feel
like my character Joe is too much
he's too much of a good guy like he needs
some kind of quirk or idiosyncrasy he's
too like he's surrounded by interesting
characters but why would he stay in that
situation I feel like he's too flat so I
feel like I don't know who Joe is I guess
he's just like this guy that's surrounded by all
these interesting people okay who is Joe then
that's what I'm trying to figure out so Joe maybe
okay his dad had this gambling addiction he found
out that his college education was gone so well
if his dad had a gambling addiction well he has
to he has to have some some serious resentments
about that and and those resentments probably
manifest themselves from some kind of problem of
his own addicts have a tendency to beget addicts
and certainly have a tendency to beget addicts
and and the terms of storytelling so that's a very
easy one to target you can there's a ton of things
you can choose from it's other psychological
issues it could be it could be alcohol he could be
a cutter he could it could be numerous things that
you can use as as tools right so Joe's not just
going to come out of the womb perfect then from
well you no he wouldn't no he wouldn't come out
of that perfect because he's he's going to he's
going to be resentful of his dad there there's
there there was a that dysfunction in this family
is going to be manifesting him even if it is in
even if it appears to be positive on the surface
the that's always fun to do is to do that little
ironic thing with a character where they where
the the negative aspect of that character looks
like it's positive at first but it's actually when
taken to an extreme it's negative would you mind
giving me an example Harrison Ford Mosquito Coast
so it looks as a positive where he's
a good protective father but instead
he takes his family to some like remote
location and like puts them through hell
you know you there's there's you can take
things that are good and you can make them
at their at an extreme bad at any time okay so
then maybe the movie opens with he and his dad
betting on football games and it's a father-son
bonding and you think wow they have such a great
relationship but then you realize that some
serious issues are happening he's owed money he
has a bookie that he owes money to and it's just
it's getting out of control but you don't see that
at first you just see this father and son watching
these games and you think well that's really neat
like they have this close relationship yeah yeah
and and and and and and and and and and and and
and to a certain extent his father can be a good
father sure he could be a good father but still be
this kind of loser there's tons of there's tons of
humans like that sure male or female yeah yeah and
so then I'm trying to think though how Joe would
be scarred from that but yeah yeah that I think
that's where my trouble lies with this character
is Joe is too perfect surrounded by some people
that they're not damaged maybe they're just very
interesting people and I've got to make Joe not so
one-dimensional I think that's my problem is that
everyone else is more lively than the protagonist
yeah or you can do some crazy stuff let's hear it
well I mean like what I mean by that is is that
there there's there's other areas that you can go
you can go you can go down the line like you're
suggesting or you can start to get meta with your
character you can you can you can trade off your
character with other characters in your story
you can you can make it appear to be about Joe
and then it actually starts to turn to be about
somebody else in the story sometimes sometimes
like the Coen brothers will give equal parity to
some characters and you'll go like I thought the
story was about this guy and why is it now about
this guy and and and and and and and and and and
that's because they're Adept at pulling that off
not ever I wouldn't suggest that a new writer
should should go out there out the gate and try
things like that but you can do stuff like that
it it's the this don't you should if you
are if you are writing and you're having
fun and you're in the zone so to speak you
shouldn't you shouldn't be limiting yourself
on ways that you can tell the story if the
story wants to go there if it's organic
if the story doesn't want to go
there then you don't go there
hmm that's interesting yeah I think I really
need to rework this character because it's
not I'm not clear on who he is I feel like
I'm clear on some of the people around him
and he's not damaged enough or fully formed
see well well what would you do in this case
so once again have you written a screenplay
before I have not no okay so so how would you
approach writing this well I think I would
try to outline it so okay I would maybe do
I know what's been popular is 24 I think it was
Adam Skelter talked about he had a teacher that
did the 24 plot points or whatever 24 beats
or whatever which is the same as 12 but it's
12 okay all right it's just doubled yeah
but and so I'm going to have the opening
of maybe on the couch and so all right we
got the the popcorn and all the stuff for
the game or whatever maybe maybe they're drinking
together Joe's over 21 and it looks like they have
this great moment so I'm going to I'm going to go
from there from that number one opening and start
and then we're going to see some stuff unravel
at home maybe some yelling with the mom
and then the the hard discussion about I'm
sorry you're not going to be able to get to
yeah but after you're done with all that you're
and you get all those those points in there
you're going to you're going to write it right
sure in in screenplay format yeah okay so I may
have screenwriting software okay okay and then
when you're when you're done writing it you're
going to have hopefully something that's going
to be around like 80 to 120 pages right okay okay
then then once you have that 80 to a
one 120 Pages the whole world changes
and I don't mean just like I don't mean like
necessarily the world of script I mean your world
because you are going to come and
look at that script with new eyes
and and and and the new eyes that you bring to
that script is going to is is going to have a
profound effect on on your protagonist and that
main character none of every anything that you
that you come out with as a as an idea for like
an outline or a thought like that is going to
is going to magically crystallize into the exact
thing that you want what happens at least to me
quite often is that I'll start off
with a vision of what I'm going for
and then along the way that vision changes and
then towards the end it really starts to really
dovetail towards the vision the original Vision
but not how I've expected never how I expect it
it dovetails towards the original Vision
but never down the road I expected to get
that's when I know that it's organic because
I will sit there and I'll go like what
this is what I want to do you this is
what new writers have to learn how to do
to make the Sophie's choice between what you
want to do and what's best to do for your script
you might sit there and go like what I really want
to do this because this is how I thought of it
no no that's not best to do for your script what's
best to do for your script is this over here
because it's where your characters want
to go it's where your story wants to go
so you need to go in that direction
and you keep going into that direction
until it all falls into place
that's the way it works it doesn't work
any other way and I would defy any any
successful writer to to to say to say
anything otherwise about that experience
it happens like that it's like you're
like wow it all worked out in the end
but never to a t but you have going on up here
at the beginning okay so I won't really know what
I'm working with until I take those 24 points and
then I put them in screenplay format write
anything from 80 to 110 Pages or thereabouts
and then maybe wait on it a week or so and then I
really am working with the beginning of the marble
that's right okay that's right
Ernest Hemingway had a famous phrase
and I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to use the
the sanitary version is that every first draft is
crap okay okay okay or poop right yeah keep it
yeah every first draft is poop okay good okay
and that that is a perennial it'll never
go away for time and memoriam for everybody
every first draft is poop even if you think
you're like no this is great no it's poop.
You're going to come back and you're going to
look at it and it's going to come together the
other thing about that this is something every
writer should know really at the end of the day
with with my familiarity with the process and with
all the writers that I've known on so many levels
successful otherwise and everything
there's no such thing as a finished screenplay
that medium never is complete you may
think it's complete it's never complete
a screenplay is finished when the director calls
action that's when it's finished there's no
there's no designated finish to a screenplay
and if a writer ever takes that for granted
that's they're they're not doing their job
writers should always be ready to come up to
bat and say I can make it better or I can I can
do this I can like communicate this better I can
do if you're if you at the if you're like on set
and the and and the director is is shooting the
film and and he says what tomorrow I'm about to
shoot these like five pages I'm not feeling it and
the producer's not feeling it can you go back and
rewrite them you're going to go back and rewrite
them you're not going to say I'm done [laughter]
if it's finished it's David Fincher it's
finished it's finished David Fincher
I mean yeah that's all you that's all you
get out of me you're not going to do that
you're going to you're going to go you're going
to go home at night and you're going to rewrite
those five pages for David Fincher and you're
going to bring them the next day and that's
how it's going to go down so yeah there's
no such thing as a finished screenplay okay
and so is it is it when the director calls cut or
is it when they calls action or she calls action
because when it's when he or she calls
it action action yeah okay it's like
because they're shooting it I mean for hopefully
they don't rewrite your your movie in post
but sometimes they do.